i am standing outside the berkhein this
is an abandoned power plant that was
turned into
the most exclusive and coolest club in
all of europe
but it is early on a sunday morning and
people are coming out but also people
are going in
do you think they're going to let me
into the club there's nothing to do with
like how you
how you dance or how you how you dress
it's like
it's like who you are you know that's
going to be a problem
they are like animals and they smell
your fear so just did you say like
they're like
enemas yeah like animals
are you aware that you're uh on the
border of kreuzberg and friedrichshain
uh this is which this is this there
there's quite
quick spirit coinsberg
[Music]
oh
do you think i would get into the
burkhain yes am i dressed okay
would i do better with your jacket
that's pretty good a little short on the
sleeve
what about your glasses you are blind as
a bat i cannot see it
all right i'm into the burkhein let's
see what happens
no yeah do i look okay
i mean if i was
i wonder if i ever saw anyone getting
rejected at that distance
you